To kind of optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Living tissue over
this episode is brought to you by Vimeo pro,
which is the ideal video hosting platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a bunch
of my startups already use Vimeo pro including Wealthfront who uses it to
explain how wealth front works task grab.
It uses it to tell their company story and there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers,
airbnb,
Etsy,
et cetera.
Why do they use it?
Well,
dimio pro provides enterprise level video hosting for a fraction of the usual
cost.
Features include gorgeous high quality playback with no ads,
up to 20 gigabytes of video storage every week.
Unlimited plays in views and a fully customizable video player,
which can include your logo,
custom outro,
et cetera.
You also get VIP support and you get all of this for just one 99 per year.
That's $17 a month with no complicated bandwidth calculations or hidden fees,
and you can try it risk free for 30 days.
So check it out.
demio.com forward slash business that's v I n e o.com forward slash business and
use Promo Code Tim to get 25% off.
That's a special discount just for you guys.
So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business Promo Code Tim.
Yeah.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming and a lot of it took place with designers from around the
world and here's how it works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward.
And many of you who are listening have already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing it in the future,
but in the meantime if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
right?
Yeah.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
I am recording this from my secret hideout in the mountains of Utah and
undisclosed location doing undisclosed things for perhaps future book
experimentation.
In any case,
this is the Tim Ferriss show where ID construct or attempt to deconstruct world
class performers of all types,
hedge fund managers,
chess prodigies,
military strategists,
you name it and we do
have a very exciting episode.
We have a lot of the baton as a guest and I'm going to describe him and explain
why you should stick around.
But first some house cleaning real fast or house keeping I suppose.
And that is a giveaway a,
it's been a long time since I give away a trip and I've been thinking about
escaping to Australia for instance and other places.
So I thought maybe you'd like to do the same.
And by that I mean I'm giving away a vacation anywhere in the world.
I've partnered with stack social and boots and all to offer you a free ride
around the globe.
Plus there are tons of other awesome prizes to check it out.
Four hour workweek.com forward slash trip,
spell it all out,
four hour work,
week.com forward slash trip doesn't cost anything and if you sign up,
you'll get a unique link.
Every time you share that on social,
you receive another five entries to improve your odds.
So hope to see you on the road,
check it out.
Four hour work week.com forward slash.
Trip.
It's pretty sweet.
The guest that we have today is along the baton,
a.
L A.
He is many things,
but I think of him as a philosopher of the most practical breed and as I've
mentioned before and written about quite extensively,
I view pragmatic philosophy as a set of rules for making better decisions in
life,
ideally in high stress environments.
So as you know,
probably I'm a huge fan of stoic philosophy alone.
In 1997,
he turned away from writing novels and instead wrote an extended essay with the
funny title how Proust can change your life,
which became an unlikely blockbuster in self help genre.
No one expected it to happen.
And Bang,
suddenly he was on the map.
His subsequent books take on all sorts of fundamental worries of modern life and
my happy,
uh,
what do I do with status,
anxiety,
etc. And this is informed by his deep reading and philosophy,
but also by his novelist's eye for small,
perfect moments.
It's a very cool combination.
His books had been described as quote,
philosophy of everyday life and are on a diverse range of subjects including
love,
travel,
architecture,
religion and work.
His bestsellers include essays and love,
how Proust can change your life status,
anxiety.
And the architecture of happiness and I'm going to include links to all of these
in the show notes@fourhourworkweek.com forward slash podcast so everything we
mentioned in the episode,
all of the goodies will be there for our work week.com forward slash podcast in
2008 the Bhutan also helped start the school of life,
which is awesome.
He's this began in London and it's a social enterprise determined to make
learning in therapy relevant in today's uptight culture.
His goal through any in all of his mediums is to help clients learn how to live
wisely and well and since I am also a student in that realm,
I wanted to get him on the phone.
Many of you asked for this conversation,
this interview,
I loved it and I hope you do as well.
Say Hi to him on Twitter.
Let him know what you thought of the interview.
If you have any followup questions,
it's at alarm,
the baton,
a l a I n d e B o t t.
O.
N on the twitters.
Please enjoy our conversation.
Thanks for listening.
Good sir.
Welcome to the show.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate you making the time to have a conversation from the other side of
the pond.
And I will admit something very embarrassing.
The good sir,
the kind,
sir.
The uh,
the so on and so forth is because I've,
I've searched far and wide to discover how to say your name correctly and didn't
want to say it incorrectly because I've had guests on like Maria Popova Popplet
sought Sulan who have had their names massacred every time that I've actually
heard it said.
So how do you pronounce your name properly,
Tim?
You're so lucky to be called Tim.
I was born on this earth with the name of Allah to bottle to bottle.
So I mean,
anything you can manage it.
Don't call me a lame,
you can call me out on.
Um,
but I don't,
I don't care.
It's just one of those things that happened.
When you're speaking with native English speakers,
how do you introduce yourself
by just saying I'm onto the bottle and you know,
see what they say,
see how they're responding.
But you know,
every,
every schoolkid in England has,
has done,
you know,
four or five years of reluctant French.
And there's always a,
there's always a,
uh,
a French teaching book with,
with a character called allow.
So they can just about Matt.
But I mean,
it's really all my fault and I'm deeply apologetic and what can I say?
It's one of those things,
that's what globalization brings us.
It's like palpable when he orders coffee at Starbucks,
he just says Pablo,
because that's what they're going to come up with anyway.
Uh,
well,
that,
that also leads me to ask it and of course we'll dig into a lot in this
conversation and I'm very excited to finally be chatting.
This has been a long time in the making.
When people ask you what do you do?
How do you answer that?
Well,
look,
the easiest thing is to say is that I'm a writer,
but,
but that doesn't really cover it because,
um,
writers come in all shapes and sizes.
If the conversation is allowed to go on a little longer.
What I tend to tell them is I'm interested in emotional intelligence and
emotional health.
Um,
it's,
it's a kind of topic that broadly pertains to all the things that make life
difficult,
that are coming from the kind of emotional centers of our brain and functioning.
Um,
you know,
sometimes people joke about first world problems,
right?
They kind of,
they laugh at how we are in the United States or the UK and they say,
you know,
you guys just,
uh,
I've got first of all problems and it's supposed to be a joke.
It's,
it's like people who are,
you know,
quibbling because the,
uh,
you know,
the Chardonnay is not chilled enough or whatever.
Um,
I actually think that that is such a thing as first of all problems,
not seen as a joke,
but seemed genuinely,
which is really the problems of advanced civilization that we're living in now
when the majority of people have got enough food,
they've got a,
a secure shelter,
but life is very tough in all sorts of ways.
So it's not the old kind of toughness.
When it was really about survival,
it's toughness of a different salt.
It's about,
uh,
trying to,
um,
make sure that your brief time on earth is well spent,
that your talents have been properly explored,
that you're in a satisfying relationship,
that you understand yourself,
that you have a purpose,
et cetera.
Now,
in many parts of the world,
these towns,
these things sound like luxuries and indeed they are,
but they are daily realities in,
in countries like the United States,
they're about 20 countries in the world where these kinds of concerns are
active.
Um,
and these are the concerns that interest me,
you know,
um,
their concerns,
as I say around,
uh,
relationships,
workplace satisfaction,
ambition,
community meaning,
I mean,
these words,
we can go into them.
They sound a little nebulous when you first mentioned them,
but it's the kind of higher order questions that people start to ask themselves.
What's the basic supply of food and shelter have been assured.
Right?
And it seems like,
uh,
when I look at,
for instance,
the cases of suicide that I've encountered in my own life,
uh,
friends who've committed suicide in,
in every case,
they're far enough up Maslow's hierarchy of needs,
that they have satisfied shelter,
hunger or food,
et cetera.
And they,
I think one of the challenges perhaps is that when people get to a certain point
and they're grappling with self actualization and so on,
there are,
there are few,
uh,
so flies in the ointment.
And I'd love to hear your thoughts on this and feel free obviously to strike me
down with a sharp blow.
But the number one is that many of the terms that are grappling with,
like you pointed out,
are in some ways nebulous.
They don't have the topics or challenges don't necessarily have clean,
clear,
uh,
evolutionary answers.
Uh,
like I am hungry,
therefore I should find food.
And in some cases we realized that what we thought would,
would address the angst or anxiety that we have,
such as a status or money,
in fact,
a appears not to provide any type of lasting relief from those types of
dilemmas.
Um,
how did you become interested in these questions?
I of course,
I mean your,
your books for instance,
had been described as a philosophy of everyday life and you've written about all
sorts of things across the board.
But how did you,
how did you fall into or become attracted to these types of questions and the
philosophy of everyday life,
if you think that's a fair description?
Um,
in the first show.
Sure.
Well,
I tend to,
um,
start always with myself,
so I'm a very personal rights.
I'm not,
I'm the opposite of an academic.
Um,
I'm looking for answers to the problems that I experienced.
I start with myself as the first case study.
And I think if I'm getting myself right,
if I'm understanding myself right,
by definition,
I'll be getting lots of other people,
right.
As well.
So,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm a laboratory.
If one,
of course I step out of that,
I read a lot,
I meet a lot of people,
I talk,
et Cetera.
But as it were,
I tend to start the emotional and the energy comes from,
you know,
the first patient me.
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
I'm the one with all the problems and um,
they tend to also just happen to be problems that other people have as well.
So quite early on in my life,
I realized that there were two things which are deeply problematic for me.
The first one was the area of love and relationships.
And the second was the area of work that these were things that were giving me
real trouble.
Um,
I think,
you know,
I've come to see with age that these are things that there wasn't a coincidence,
that these are the two areas of massive insecurity,
doubt and most important,
the lack of guidance.
You know,
we,
we live in a society where we very much believe in freedom and individual,
um,
self realization,
which is fantastic from one point of view and leaves us desperately searching
for guidance,
clues,
et cetera.
And we left very much alone.
You know,
I had a so called elite education.
I went to Cambridge University in the UK.
I got a good degree,
et cetera.
So I was it kind of well educated citizen of the modern world.
And yet,
boy,
oh boy,
I was so lost.
Um,
I just didn't know,
you know,
I hadn't had enough of the right sort of conversations.
I hadn't met the right sort of people.
Broadly speaking,
I wasn't living in a therapeutic environment.
I don't mean Oprah.
I don't mean a psychoanalyst.
I mean,
uh,
it literally in the ancient Greek sense therapy,
which is the kind of nourishment and nurture of the soul,
the inner bit,
the precious bit of you.
Um,
there just wasn't any support.
Uh,
I was,
I felt very cut off from that.
And gradually I felt my way through books,
through conversations,
um,
to a kind of way of living where I could just begin to understand some of the
things that I was suffering from.
But if I were to diagnose my younger self,
I was a classic example of,
you know,
somebody living in a,
a prosperous world city in the middle of a kind of heyday of capitalism.
Um,
uh,
suffering from all the anx that comes with that.
I'd been taught that happiness,
personal happiness came from war.
Finding one very,
very special person with whom there would be an ecstatic sense of communion.
Um,
and uh,
she happened to be,
and I would meet,
it would be wonderful.
My all sense of loneliness,
loss and drift would be healed.
They would be,
it would be like a,
a sort of secularized version of a meeting with the deity.
And I was on the lookout in bars,
clubs,
dinner parties for this person,
this,
this angelic datey who'd,
who'd graciously come down to earth.
And that that was going to solve my love from that.
I also was facing a work problem.
And the,
the kind of ideology I'd grown up with was,
you're going to work very,
very hard.
Uh,
and then you will find a precious bit of you and you will put that on a
commercial basis.
Whatever it is,
that inner precious core,
you will turn into money in,
in good time.
Uh,
you know,
you will be both creative and also financially productive,
et cetera.
Now,
I'm not saying that either of these things is impossible,
but they're very hard and were very alone with them alone.
Indeed.
Um,
and this struck me and my career in many ways was designed to try and find some
answers that would work for me and would work for others.
And by answers,
I don't only mean solutions.
I also mean interpretations.
You know,
when you're,
when you're suffering from something you don't necessarily always want or expect
there to be a fixed,
but at least just understanding what it is that's the problem.
Uh,
and,
and express kind of eloquently,
that's at least half the battle.
And I didn't have any of that.
And that's what my career has been spent trying to do.
What did you study in Undergrad where it was it your undergraduate studies?
I studied,
uh,
what they called over the history of ideas,
which was a wonderful course that really looks at the evolution of big concepts
through time and how attitudes to different things that change.
So we were studying word like freedom and look at all the different ways in
which that word has changed and how differently it was interpreted,
say in the fifth century,
a d two the way it was interpreting the 18th century,
the way it was interpreted in America versus in China,
et Cetera.
So that was really fun and,
and,
and really good.
And from,
from that point,
grappling with all of these issues as many people do.
What put you on the,
the uh,
the map,
so to speak,
as a,
as a discusser,
a explorer of these ideas.
You have of course a very well known extended essay called how Proust can change
your life.
That's another one I had to look up before this interview.
I'm going to admit I had to look up p r o u s e to double check and make sure
that I would be pronouncing it somewhat close to correct,
thick.
How Proust can change your life.
Is that the essay that kind of put you into the mainstream or slipstream or,
or were there other ways that you were able to test your ideas on a,
on a large public scale before that?
So when I graduated,
um,
I was very aware the time was short and that are immense pressures on young
people to prove themselves pretty early on.
And I felt that very much like I'd come from a family of high achievers and I
was born with a sort of sense of like,
you know,
you've got to prove yourself.
And,
um,
it was a kind of madness.
I now recognize it.
It was,
it was not easy or the best thing.
I don't think that's a,
a great ideology to have,
but,
but there we have it.
So no sooner did I graduate that I really started asking him as of the biggest
questions.
Like,
where do I want my life to go?
I applied for various jobs,
but I'd graduated in the midst of a recession and it was very hard to find what
when was,
this was one,
this was the summer of 1991.
And,
um,
a lot of my friends would just,
you know,
finding things to do,
taking jobs in bars,
et cetera.
And I asked myself,
what do I really want to do?
And I thought what I really want to do is write books.
Um,
and I dare to admit that to myself in a kind of late nights session of,
of self honesty.
And I thought will,
I wanted,
I just start now and I've been thinking a lot about writing and self expression
and all the rest of it.
And so I kind of gradually felt my way to writing my first book,
which was published when I was just 22.
Um,
and it was a book of essays in laugh in the u s it was title on love.
And um,
I put my heart and soul into it.
It's a very intimate dissection of a love story.
And the book did very well.
I mean,
very well,
certainly for a 22,
23 year old.
And it gave me the confidence and the courage to carry on and relatively soon
after I then wrote what turned out to be my breakthrough book,
which was called how Proust can change your life and thanks to American readers
and reviewers.
That book did extremely well and it was an unlikely moment,
um,
because he was a book written about,
uh,
early 20th century,
great French writer that was at the same time it's self help book.
Um,
and I deliberately chose to kind of mash up these two jars are kind of scholarly
essay and a self help book.
It wasn't just a,
a kind of um,
slide commercial trick.
There was serious intent,
which is that I always felt that high culture,
by which I mean,
you know,
literature,
philosophy,
uh,
you know,
plays,
et cetera.
These things do not just belong in the ivory tower.
They have a richness to them which can be absorbed and should be transmitted to
the widest possible public.
This is heresy among the universities that believe partly for economic reasons,
but only if you enroll in that sacred a fraternity.
Do you really have the right tools to be able to interpret an enjoy the
masterpieces of civilization?
I passionately disagreed with that.
I am by nature a popularizer and a Democrat of the mind.
And I did not appreciate that kind of cloistered vision of knowledge.
So I took a lot of what I'd been thinking and reading and really tried to
express it so clearly,
and I would write sentences 20 times to make sure that they could be understood
by everyone.
Um,
I would try material out on people who've been educated and people who had been
educated at all and I wanted to make sure that it would work at all levels.
And so that was,
uh,
an extra layer of work and I'm really proud and happy to say it did work and the
book proved itself around the world.
And so I was in the very Auden fortunate position that come the age of 27.
I'd had this book that had worked,
um,
and,
and I was kind of,
uh,
you know,
I was a loft,
um,
at least,
you know,
for a time.
So that's yeah,
that's how we ended up doing what I do.
And,
and for people who have not read,
uh,
let's just take on love and how Proust can change your life.
Was on love,
autobiographical.
Was it a novel?
Was it a mix of the two?
Neither.
It,
it was a mix of the two.
Cause Tim,
you know what I love about novels is the local color of the intimacy of
language.
The kind of the sense that you're suddenly in a real place and you know what the
weather's like and et cetera.
We're drives me crazy about novels is that sometimes you feel that the novelist
is cleverer than they're allowing their characters to be.
You feel that there's all sorts of stuff that is discussed in nonfiction ways
that somehow just doesn't find its way into the novel where it's all supposed to
be about showing,
not telling.
And I didn't like those rules.
So my novel was explicitly and attempt to tell a love story as well as show it
to have a mixture of analysis and also more sensory descriptive bits.
Cause I wanted to touch the reader and make them think,
I didn't want to tell just another ordinary love story.
I wanted to analyze love in the course of a love story so that the kind of the
knowledge bits would be well wrapped up some of the excitement of a love story.
So it was,
it was kind of trying out a genre and then all my works,
I've always been a little impatient by the,
the kind of models out there for how to write like a classic novel must be,
you know,
x pages long must feature that.
I,
I've always been provoked to slightly pool at those rules.
And um,
so just as I read a self help book,
but you know,
it was half about this great 20th century writer and that's not normal.
So I was writing a novel,
but that wasn't quite the normal way of writing the novel.
So I was impatient with some of the,
the rules that writers get.
Given what,
um,
which,
which writers or books most influenced your approach?
You're thinking about those two books on love or we get focused on how Proust
can change your life.
Um,
look,
the books that I always most enjoyed with the books,
first of all,
where you feel the presence of an author in the text,
who feels like a nice person.
I know that could sound kind of trivial,
but,
um,
it just sounds like someone that you could kind of get to know and have a,
have a chat with.
I mean,
if we think of someone like Thoreau,
um,
thorough sounds like a really great guy.
Uh,
he's friendly,
he's sometimes sarcastic,
but he's always witty,
he's humane,
he's generous,
he's sometimes impatient,
et cetera.
But you kind of get a sense of a person.
Um,
you get that sometimes reading great writers letters,
you know,
if you read,
I don't know,
the journals of Nathaniel Hawthorne for example,
um,
you can,
you get a flavor of,
of a person.
So,
um,
someone like the French philosopher Martinia was a great influence.
He was a man writing in the 16th century.
Again,
just spoken this wonderfully direct,
intimate way.
So,
yes,
he was telling you about Plato and he was telling you about history,
et cetera.
But you always felt I'm actually with someone and I've always really appreciated
the personal voice and um,
and that really influenced how I wanted to,
to write and be with my readers.
And I will admit when it comes to,
uh,
most philosophy,
I'm kind of a one trick pony.
Uh,
I've,
I've really read a lot of stoic philosophy,
but outside of that,
uh,
I'm woefully inadequate.
So I'm going to ask a question that you've no doubt been asked before that maybe
really irritating,
but how can Proust change your life?
What is the,
uh,
what is the structure of the book or what is the,
um,
what,
what are some of the theses or concepts?
So,
um,
Proust is really a philosopher more than a novelist.
And his book is about such for how you can stop wasting your life and start to
appreciate life and live fully.
So the title is very accurate.
The title of his long book is in search of lost time and it's literally one man
search for how you can stop wasting your life.
And it follows the uh,
the rater hero as he tries out.
Three things that he thinks may turn out to be the meaning of life.
The first things he,
first thing he tries his social status position in society and a lot of the book
follows how he tries to get in with the top people in Paris.
He wants to get in with,
uh,
nowadays they would be the celebrities,
the business people,
et cetera.
But in those days they were the aristocrats and so he's trying to get in with
them.
He's trying to make a name for himself,
et Cetera.
And it follows,
it's very funny,
it's warm,
it's self deprecating,
but essentially the search for the journey,
he does manage to get into the inner sanctum,
but he discovers that actually these people are often brutal,
brutish,
not that interesting and not really interested in him properly.
And he has a kind of moment of existential despair around this goal of social
status.
He then moves on to another possible goal of life,
which is romantic love.
And a lot of the novel is spent tracing the love affair of the narrator for a
beautiful late teenage girl called Albertine who's charming,
had strong gammy mean the kind of boyish a charmer and um,
brought to there are all sorts of disappointments and he realizes some of the
real limitations of love,
which is that we go to love because we think that someone will understand this
fully,
that we can be fulfilled totally in the arms of another persons that are and
gently and with humor and Proust unpicks some of these hopes.
And again,
gradually we realized that love,
like social status is perhaps not the meaning of life.
So what is well,
Proust ends up like many writers defending his own art and craft.
He defends art as the meaning of life.
And what he means by art is it's going to be,
don't ask a barber if you need a haircut,
kind of fit.
It's a big,
big PDR job on,
on,
on art,
but he's more generous.
You can certainly read him in ways that are more generous than merely art.
As An,
you know,
you've got to immediately enroll on a fine arts degree or something.
He's not saying that he is seeing the great works of art,
not all art,
but the great works of art as examples of life as it's lived to the full.
And he's interested in,
in particular in certain artists.
So he talks a lot about the painter,
the Dutch painter,
Vermeer who he thinks are rising.
That's right.
And what he appreciates is that Vermeer painted daily life,
but he saw in daily life an extraordinary richness,
uh,
and uh,
and,
you know,
level of kind of psychological involvement,
et Cetera,
that he was,
he was living life to the full.
So he,
another painter he really liked was a French 18th century painter Sharda who
rather like Vermeer painted modest interiors,
um,
families around the kitchen table,
loaves of bread,
the painted about 20 loaves of bread.
Um,
one of the first mentors to kind of spend so long with bread.
And really it's a kind of,
you know,
it's very fresh.
It's also a kind of secularized Christian message,
which is really that ordinary,
modest life has grace has,
is in contact with the glory and dignity of the universe kind of thing to put it
in a sacred and exactly.
Exactly.
And,
um,
and,
and this is what makes Preuss such an enchanting writer that he,
he is so interested in daily life and he wants to make daily life magical.
And that's what he resents and hates about snobbery because snobbery constantly
makes you think that there's a group of people out there who are special,
more special than the ordinary people,
um,
et cetera.
And Proust,
you know,
the son of a kind of ought bourgeois,
wealthy family,
et Cetera,
has this tremendously,
deeply,
profoundly democratic vision,
um,
about the value of each individual and the capacity of an artistic gaze to tease
out that value and therefore thereby make life meaningful.
So that's some of what I discovered.
And that provided the spine for my own,
uh,
a study of Proust,
that I wrote.
So I have to,
uh,
immediate responses.
The first is,
have you seen a documentary called Tim's Vermeer by any chat?
I haven't.
Oh,
it is spectacular.
It is about a computer scientists and
a very famous entrepreneur in these desktop editing world who is an incredible
inventor also,
uh,
outside of those fields and decides he wants to determine how Vermeer painted
the way he painted and goes through many different attempts,
uh,
builds many different tools to try to replicate Vermeer paintings.
It's,
it's a very fascinating,
hilarious,
uh,
and insightful look at yet another obsessive,
not saying you're obsessive,
but the world is full of interesting.
Obsessives the second,
uh,
is,
how did reading Proust or writing this book as you're really dug into it,
uh,
affect how you prioritized or lived your life?
How did you,
how did you incorporate that into your decisions?
Priorities are,
um,
look,
I think the liberation of that book for me was,
um,
going up to a really big name and authority that was spoken off by professors in
reverential tones.
And what I did with that is to fire some pretty naive questions at this kind of
colossus of kind of western culture.
And I really asked the most essential but the most naive question,
which is how can you help me to live?
Uh,
and I think in a way this is the best question to ask anyone.
One meets in many ways that's what you tend to ask in your podcasts.
Um,
it's such a valuable question to ask very often.
We're too shy.
We,
we're were reserved.
We think that other people are going to be bored by that question or um,
you know,
everyone else knows it already,
et cetera.
The book liberated me to be a kind of person who would be able to go up to works
of high culture and culture generally and kind of shake down on the tree and see
what there was for all of us.
Uh,
and um,
uh,
so that's,
that that was the kind of personal discovery
and that,
so in sort of knocking at the door of this colossus and daring to ask these
questions about practicality that opened the door to then your career as a
writer and exploration of that in,
in,
in that sense.
Is that what you mean?
Or is there,
are there ways that,
uh,
Proust impacted in the answers that you got back in your exploration your data?
Yes.
I mean,
I guess both,
um,
uh,
to,
to address the kind of the second very good point.
I think that there were many attitudes that I found improvs that were incredibly
seductive and charming in the,
in the best sense.
So Preuss,
um,
anti romanticism,
but,
but I mean by romanticism,
mmm Preuss was reacting against many of the things that he saw in the 19th
century that he disagreed with the idea of the individual as a hero.
The idea of love is the answer to everything.
The idea of,
um,
certain kinds of career success as being,
you know,
the only way to live,
et cetera.
He,
he,
he took a kind of a skeptical position,
visa vi a lot of these things.
Um,
it wasn't a pretty rejected them wholeheartedly,
but he was a little skeptical,
beautifully skeptical.
And,
um,
and I found in him a kind of,
you could say you're kind of maturity that I didn't necessarily possess at that
age.
I was 26,
25,
26.
And,
um,
and I learned from him,
it was like sitting at the feet of a kind of wise person who's seen a few things
and who says,
you know,
steady on,
calm down,
maybe,
you know,
look at it this way.
Um,
and uh,
he,
yeah,
he gracefully prized me from certain of my more immature positions.
Uh,
in relation to a number of things,
could you give some examples?
Well,
for example,
you know,
I had mentioned love,
but it's not that I am now cynical about love,
but um,
in a way he,
he rather dark Proust rather darkly says all of us cannot be understood by
another human being perfectly.
That there is an area of loneliness inside everybody.
And to blame someone for not understanding you fully,
um,
is deeply unfair because first of all,
we don't understand ourselves.
And even if we do understand ourselves,
we have such a hard time communicating ourselves to other people and therefore
to be furious and enraged and bitter that people don't get all of,
you know,
all of who we are is,
is a real,
is a really kind of crucial piece of immaturity.
And that came as a real shock to me,
you know,
as a,
as a guy in his twenties who,
who really thought,
no,
love is this sort of magical communion where,
um,
you know,
I see into their soul,
they see into mine,
there are no secrets and there is no more loneliness.
Um,
and I've realized that there's a kind of beautiful intolerance,
so both beautiful but really kind of negative.
It's,
it's,
it's the breeding ground of a certain kind of impatience and that's kind of
dangerous and that helped me a lot in my personal relationships.
I think it made me a slightly more,
more,
more patient,
more humble kind of person to be around.
And uh,
I have so many questions for you.
The,
uh,
the,
this is mostly just a,
a therapy session for myself disguised as a podcast.
But the,
um,
the,
the first question that,
that I'd love to ask is building on that.
I remember one point,
um,
there was a poll or a,
some type of research done.
I don't know how well it was put together and it said that,
uh,
you know,
the,
the happiest country in the world is Denmark.
So based on these various surveys and the data that's been gathered,
the Danish are the happiest people.
And I got a comment on a post I put up about this from a Danish person who said,
the secret to happiness is low expectations.
That's a pretty common belief here in Denmark.
And I thought it was very funny.
And then I,
I then I,
upon looking at it a second time,
began to ask,
is there actually something there?
Right.
And if there is,
how do you,
how do you combine ideally low expectations so you're not constantly
disappointed,
I.
E the,
the opposite of expecting your loved one to solve all of your loneliness and
Abcd,
you F and g while still striving,
uh,
or,
or doing great things for yourself or other people.
Um,
and you,
of course,
I've written a lot since and done many things and,
and we'll dig into some of them.
But how do you think about that?
Um,
I think it's such a key question.
I think you're,
you're putting your finger on,
on a key thing,
which is that very often people think that having sure we could call a mature
expectations or slightly low expectations in some areas,
um,
is going to mean that you lose ambition,
that you cannot have ambition and realism.
You cannot be sober in some areas and still deeply excited to get out of bed in
the morning.
Um,
I think that's not really true.
I think there is,
you could have these what you could call paradoxical positions on issues.
For example,
you know,
I like to explore the idea of being a cheerful pessimists or you go,
hang on,
how can you be a cashier for past,
right?
But,
but if you explore that,
you know,
if you're a little pessimistic but about how a lot of things go,
it doesn't necessarily mean that you're going to be gloomy all the time.
You may encounter moments of pure ecstasy as you realize,
um,
that there are some very fine things in a world which is otherwise very dark.
Um,
I don't think a backdrop of stock realism slash pessimism about all sorts of
things that,
you know,
death and illness can visit us very suddenly without warning.
But all our granters plans can be undone by a blood clot in under a minute.
Um,
that some of the finest ambitions fall prey to,
you know,
the meanest realities,
et Cetera,
that,
that many of us,
perhaps all of us are going to go to our deathbeds with some very important
parts of us still unexplored.
Um,
I think it's because things are so dark because we are operating against a
backdrop of,
of darkness that,
you know,
a glass of beautiful lemon juice or a sincere conversation with a friend or a
moment when yes,
things do go right and everything.
It does go right.
Why these things matter so much and perhaps much more intensely.
It's,
it's like the joy of the convalescent who's come out of the hospital and they
are seeing the sunlight strike,
you know,
the leaves of a Daffodil.
And that Daffodil seems more beautiful than it's ever done to the robust,
you know,
football player who hasn't ever,
pause to,
uh,
to appreciate these things.
So I,
as I say,
um,
I think it's,
it should be utterly compatible with ambition,
appreciation,
uh,
tenderness,
et Cetera,
to,
to keep the really grim things not far from the top of consciousness,
kind of pretty much every day.
The who are some philosophers or thinkers,
uh,
that for those people who have,
a lifelong aversion to the word philosophy in the concept of philosophy,
uh,
for just from a utilitarian standpoint,
a readability standpoint,
maybe they're not the same,
but who,
who are,
who are some names that come to mind that you would recommend to folks as a
gateway drug to,
uh,
to philosophy?
Well,
that's such a good question.
I mean,
first of all,
I'd like to apologize on path of philosophy.
It's not my role,
but I'll do it anyway.
Playfully.
Um,
the general public's disinterest and suspicion of philosophy is,
well,
it's does the general public hasn't just forgotten about philosophy by mistake?
Philosophers operating today have on the whole forgotten about the public.
Um,
insofar my point of view as philosophy is interesting.
I think it's,
it's most interesting at,
it's very in,
it's very opening moves.
When philosophy begins in ancient Greece and Rome,
uh,
it sets out to be therapy for the soul.
It sets out to be a practical tool that can help you to live and die.
Well,
philosophers in those days are interested in finding out how families were,
how money works,
how status works,
what we should do about public opinion,
what we should do about death and illness and ambition and all of these things
that trouble us every day.
That was,
you know,
that centrally what philosophers were interested in and discussed and the great
philosophers of those days,
people like Epicurus,
like Seneca,
Marcus are really us.
Plato,
you know,
these people are all very much worth reading.
Um,
philosophy continues to be interesting for many centuries.
I mentioned the name of mortality early on.
He's fantastic.
Uh,
in the 19th century,
you've got a great German philosopher Schopenhauer.
He's fantastic.
You get nature.
We can be read with a very rewarding,
uh,
results when we hit the 20th century.
The number of interesting philosophers tails off because something happens to
philosophy that is not often remarked upon,
which is basically it splits into and for my money.
The interesting stuff goes into psychology.
Freud says that he is a philosopher.
Um,
and you know,
the whole tradition that comes out of fraud,
not just like analysis,
but,
but psychology more generally.
Um,
the,
the interesting stuff about how to live,
how our minds work,
how to actualize ourselves,
how to relate to others as these things become the province of psychology.
And throughout it,
his street philosophies had a habit of casting off bits of itself and kind of
that spurn the,
the,
the spur on sort of sub genres.
It used to be that the study of the stars was what philosophies did,
uh,
now you know,
that's astrophysics.
So,
um,
philosophy has this split in the 20th century and nowadays philosophers tend to
be really only ever employed by universities or was it danger sign when your,
when your subject,
your subject matter,
when no one will pay directly for your subject matter,
that's often a sign that something's gone wrong.
Um,
the canary in the coal mine is getting a little wobbly.
That's right.
So,
and,
and that's deserved because philosophers don't tell us how to live and die
anymore.
There are a few,
there's a great philosopher who was at Princeton called Martha Nussbaum.
She's terrific.
There are a few others out there who are doing good work,
but really not very many,
not very many that you would recommend.
Let's see.
I don't know.
You had a friend who was interested in philosophy and was having a little hard
time in life.
There's very few names that you would recommend.
Nevertheless,
what philosophy really is,
is a discipline that's distinct from say,
poetry or religion,
but like poetry.
It wants to talk about the things that are meaningful.
Um,
and like religion,
it wants to give us guidance.
But unlike religion,
it's not using the supernatural.
It's no appeal to supernatural or,
or,
um,
you know,
mysterious forces,
forces you can't define.
Um,
it's,
it's based on anything that you can kind of reason with.
Um,
and,
and unlike poetry,
it's not merely interested in kind of beautiful phenomena.
It wants to take those somewhere.
It wants to inform and,
and reform us.
So the book I wrote after I wrote half Bruce can change your life,
was a book called the constellations of philosophy.
And in that book,
I looked at sixth grade philosophers,
I looked at Socrates,
Epicurus,
Seneca,
Martain,
Schopenhauer,
uh,
nature.
And,
um,
I,
I looked at these guys as for very practical guidance.
It was an attempt to say to these great names,
how can you show us,
you know,
what to do and,
and how to live.
Uh,
and,
um,
uh,
you know,
so that was a kind of classic style that I was developing.
And,
um,
and then I was getting good results from,
and uh,
you know,
that's,
that's a book of mine that,
that one,
many readers around the world and it's still probably the book of mine that
sells the best.
Um,
and it,
it's,
you know,
it does what it says on the tin,
which is to look for constellations among the work of some great philosophers.
Do you consider Bertrand Russell a philosopher?
Absolutely.
Um,
he,
I was,
I was always very impressed.
I was introduced to Bertrand Russell before I was introduced to Seneca and then
visa vi Seneca in delving into stoicism.
Uh,
of course he has a very interesting,
uh,
he is a very interesting style of prose and discourse.
So he throws in his company his competition,
right?
He throws in Epicurus quite a bit as a way to pull in defectors,
which is very clever of him and not too surprising if you look at his political
hardwiring,
but Burke.
But Bertrand Russell was the first one and I'm not sure if it was a,
there's a,
there's uh,
I've read several of his books,
but you know why I am not a Christian was one of the secrets of happiness,
the secrets of happiness also.
Yes.
That may have been the first.
And now I was struck by how much it,
uh,
how strongly it contrast it to most of the philosophy I had been exposed to.
I went to Princeton undergraduate,
I did take one philosophy class that was very,
very,
very good with the Professor Rosen and I'm blanking on the,
uh,
I think it was metaphysics and epistemology one-on-one,
which I probably couldn't define either of those terms at this point,
but professor Rosen was very good.
And then the rest that I ran into release seemed like a lot of intellectual
masturbation,
um,
where
a vast majority of it seemed to focus on a semantic tail,
chasing the sort of,
the,
the like what does is really mean?
And then they'd go on for 600 pages of rhetoric and at the end you're like,
I don't think that added any value.
Yep.
You mean to my,
I so sympathize that was my experience as well and it enrages me and saddens me.
And I think that,
um,
look,
I'm,
you know,
the older I get,
the more I realized that the great challenge of our own age is to take the good
ideas and make them available to a wide public.
And the universities often weirdly the opposite.
I mean,
they,
they inform a kind of narrow coterie of students,
but there are,
they stand outside the kind of democratic project.
And that's critical because we live in a mass culture.
We live,
we live in a world where ideas have to have followings in the millions if that
ever to get traction.
And when people,
you know,
uh,
wring their hands and despair and go,
why don't we do this?
Why don't we do that a wise,
the world,
et Cetera.
A lot of the reason is that the good ideas are not on network TV.
They're not on the mass channels communication.
So that a few people in the Ivy League universities,
I've got full command of,
you know,
if it can Stein's later philosophy,
but out in the street that isn't,
you know,
that democratic pool of knowledge.
And you know,
I've always been attracted to the Great Democrats of knowledge.
So someone like Voltaire in 18th Century France,
he wanted to write for everybody.
Um,
uh,
you know,
someone like Emerson in the American tradition,
again,
he was a man who toured the country and gave impassioned speeches about the
highest and most meaningful things,
but he was,
you know,
in,
in the church hall talking,
you know,
the language of ordinary people to get his message across.
And that seem,
that seems to have been so hard for many 20th century philosophers.
And Bertrand Russell is,
you know,
in a company of almost just one in,
in,
in his decision that he was a guy who he,
he wrote a,
he had a column in,
in,
in a,
in a daily newspaper in England.
He wrote articles for American vogue.
He appeared on television.
He had a regular radio program.
Many philosophers attacked him for this.
They said that he was cheapening and deadening his son Jay,
but it was a man who knew his stuff.
He wasn't going to be bullied and patronized.
And he understood that the things he cared about would only live if he managed
to get ordinary people properly engage.
So he was a wonderful,
wonderful vulgarized.
Ah,
in the best sense.
No,
I,
uh,
I agree and I think that one of the challenges is that when you had,
say the Stoics,
right?
Steaua as I understand it,
referring to porch and they would sit in these informal classrooms and talk.
I mean there are other forms of course fora.
Maybe,
I dunno,
I'm not up to speed with my etymology,
but the,
when that translated into a more structured academic setting,
uh,
and say the hard sciences had a progression in difficulty,
right?
Where you,
if you're willing to study at the graduate level,
uh,
in mathematics,
you need to master the Prereq,
the prerequisites and undergraduate and then Algebra and so on before that.
And when you take philosophy and force fit it into that type of progression,
you go from,
uh,
not striving to make something useful,
but striving to make something difficult.
And I think when it becomes difficult,
it's inversely correlated to its usefulness.
Does that make sense?
It's like,
well,
you can't be a phd in philosophy until you've made it sufficiently arcane and
made the rhetoric so convoluted that only five people at this university are
willing to sit down and talk about it for three hours.
And it's,
uh,
it becomes this very unfortunate,
sort of self,
uh,
cauterizing structure.
You know,
the unfortunate thing is that the humanities,
so all the great wisdom of the,
at a professional level,
they started to have to compete in the 20th century with the sciences for money
and attention and universities.
And the way that they decided to take the battle is that they sort of tried to
turn themselves into pseudo sciences so that they suggested that you would study
them,
like a scientist would,
would start it.
So you would do things like research,
you would find a poet and you would research the poet and you would do some kind
of complicated weird stuff in the,
in the back engine room around that.
They're,
this person.
Previously the humanities was,
wasn't the handle.
They weren't handled like this.
They were handled by,
by ordinary lay people who would spend half an hour in the evening dipping into,
you know,
have a volume of philosophy,
all poetry.
Um,
suddenly this stuff became the subject of kind of,
you know,
study that was akin to studying nuclear physics.
Um,
and that was all to make sure that the professors would get tenure and that
departments would get funding and that governments would be suitably impressed.
I can understand and sympathize with,
you know,
people's needs to,
progress up the career ladder.
But it's been a complete disaster for the rest of us because it's meant that
wisdom that was supposed to circulate freely and democratically around the
nation has become,
you know,
bunched up in some kind of centers,
um,
uh,
in the universities and,
and is not doing its job.
And meanwhile,
you know,
well we know,
we know what happens on TV and down the down the airwaves,
how I'm not how,
who do you think the contemporary thinkers who are doing a good job of
popularizing,
what you might consider philosophy,
um,
who are names that come to mind?
Of course you're,
you are one of the first names that come to mind for most people,
but who else would you put on that list?
Um,
well I have a colleague that I like very much called John Armstrong who operates
out of Australia and he's,
he's,
he writes some wonderful things.
Um,
there are also,
as I mentioned,
she smuggled Martha Nussbaum who's,
who's doing a really nice job.
Um,
you know,
they've been,
they've been Arthur's.
Um,
but it's,
you know,
it,
it is hard.
Um,
popularization is,
is hard.
Um,
one of my favorite popularizes is Jamie Oliver,
the cook chef.
And what I love about the guys that he's taught the UK how to cook,
um,
and the way he's done that is to speak in the language of ordinary people about
some pretty unordinary things like how to cook a duck,
Allah,
Raj or something.
And he's got working class English males to kind of put on an apron and do some
weird stuff.
And I think that's what a good teacher is.
A good teacher is the person who takes your fear.
And we tend to have these fears like,
I'm a woman so I can't,
or I come from a working class background,
so I can't,
or you know,
I'm uh,
you know,
an elite person.
So I can't,
we have these kind of blocks.
I can't do this because of that in my past.
And a good teacher says,
no,
how do you mean you can't do engineering and be a woman?
Of course you can,
or you know,
you,
you can't be a working class guy and read poetry course you can,
et cetera.
And that's what a good teacher does,
shakes you free from some of these kinds of dichotomies.
And,
uh,
so for me,
you know,
a good teacher of philosophy is that someone who comes down the audience,
like,
you know,
you thought that because you're a busy dentist,
you can't read philosophy.
It has no place in your life.
Of course you can.
Uh,
so that's,
that's what a good teacher does.
And,
and you know that those are some out there.
and,
and we need more.
I agree on Jamie Oliver.
I have,
uh,
one of his books cook with Jamie about 15 feet in front of me on a shelf next to
a couple of other people.
I would put in that same category of teacher.
Uh,
you have,
uh,
seven fires,
which is one many people probably haven't heard of,
which is by a Patagonian chef trained in France about how to use fire to us.
But the,
the underlying,
the underlying principles are the same.
Whether it's Richard Feynman,
the physicist,
one of my favorite books.
Surely you must be joking,
Mr Feinman or seven fires or Jamie Oliver.
I mean they're,
they are making the,
the,
the potentially complex simple to encourage the free flow of,
of ideas and action.
And it's the opposite of making the potentially simple complicated to constrain
the flow because you have a scarcity mindset,
you have a defensive mindset,
which would be the case I think for,
for many people at the highest levels of academia,
which is unfortunate.
They feel like if they were to popularize,
it would,
uh,
it would sort of loosen the soil beneath their feet and remove some stability in
some way,
uh,
or,
or cheapen it.
And I'm not sure when that happened.
I mean in the day of say,
um,
I,
there's,
there's a book I really need to read call.
I think it's dying every day.
It's a book about Seneca in the Court of narrow,
but was set up.
It was a very,
very popular writer.
Uh,
do you have any idea if he was ridiculed and scoffed at by the highbrow
philosophers of his day or did that,
is that a recent develop?
Um,
well,
he,
he was ridiculed not for,
not for that issue,
but he was ridiculed for making a lot of money,
uh,
which he did,
um,
in,
in politics and business.
And also,
um,
having a pretty luxurious lifestyle.
And people said,
how do you mean,
hang on,
I had him,
you're supposed to be a stoic philosopher.
You're supposed to have one cloak and,
and live in a thing,
and your,
your,
you know,
your house is pretty nice.
And so there was some mockery and he has some funny answers to that.
I mean,
he,
he rebuts the judge's head on and he says the true philosopher,
it's not the true philosopher,
must have no money.
It's just that he must be ready to lose it.
That he must is,
hold on.
It must be relaxed and,
um,
right.
And in fact,
you know,
this could sound like,
oh yeah,
you know,
pull the other leg.
But,
but in fact,
he did practice what he preached because twice in his life he did lose
everything.
He was exiled,
he fell into political disgrace,
et cetera.
And,
um,
he,
he behaves pretty well.
Um,
and so stoicism is not necessarily,
stoicism attracted a lot of support on the very wealthy and the very successful
because it taught them that they could survive without their wealth and their
success.
And very often when people get wealthy and successful,
they become very scared of what would happen and they feel the need for ever
more success and have a more wealth from a fear that if they would have to go
backwards,
it would be catastrophic.
And what's very relaxing and nice about stoicism is that it partly says,
will,
you know,
uh,
it's survivable.
Of course it is.
And one of the favorite stoic exercises that they would perform was that once a
month or so,
um,
a stoic was advised to wear the dirtiest cloak and sleep on the kitchen floor.
Santa Clara advised in the dog basket.
Uh,
I don't know how big that that might be.
And you would drink the dog's water.
And the idea was that for,
for,
for a few days,
you live like a dog and you realize that that's possible and it's fine.
And that removes,
um,
fear.
And as they understood,
he coming back to your earlier issue about ambition,
they realize that often what stops us from realizing our ambitions is fear and
therefore if we make ourselves totally at home with failure totally at home with
utter disgrace,
we will feel a curious lightness and sense of possibility because we weren't
held back by the constant thought.
What happens if we will have fully explored the question?
What happens if we'll have made ourselves so at home and seen that there is
nothing so bad about failure and that will free us to advance more likely and
with greater courage towards some of our goals.
I couldn't agree more.
And you're retching pessimism earlier.
I give a presentation I think in 2008 2009 it's only five or six minutes long
called a practical pessimism and it made the point like,
like you just did very eloquently,
that if you practice the worst case scenario,
and even if you were to view that as pessimism but a very practical version of
it,
it actually frees you to be more ambitious.
It doesn't teach you to drop your expectations.
It just teaches you not to be attached to the expectation of a best case
scenario.
So it frees you up to swing for the fences because you're not afraid of striking
out.
At least I've found that to be true for myself.
And there's a,
there's a great essay also out there on the,
uh,
the,
the discussion and the Aha,
the stone throwing,
uh,
related to Seneca and as well,
I mean,
he was very well known for being wealthy and,
uh,
had his ivory legged tables and so on.
There's an essay called the,
the case of the opulent Stoic,
which is a very interesting read on how that controversy evolved and where it
may be a fair accusation at where it may be an unfair accusation.
Um,
but,
uh,
what a wonderful essay.
Oh yeah.
It's a great,
great name too.
Just like the in search of lost time.
Um,
the,
uh,
where did all this come from?
I'm,
so,
I've been in so much as,
where did you grow up?
What did your parents do?
Could you give us some color as to your,
your upbringing?
The Pre k the pre k?
Yeah.
So I came from a family of very displaced,
very neurotic and anxious immigrants.
My father was born in Egypt.
He was part of the Jewish community in Alexandria that got kicked out in the
50s.
From one day to the next.
He then drifted around the Middle East.
He eventually wound up as a,
as an immigrant,
as a refugee,
more or less in Switzerland.
Um,
was utterly penniless and desperate.
Met My mother who was a part of the Swiss Jewish community and for all her own
reasons to have a family,
had our father had recently died.
The family had lost everything for having come from quite a privileged
background.
They then lost everything and she was living,
um,
in very humble second.
And where they found each other,
they clung to each other and they were United in their desire to make it in life
and to be ambitious and achieve great things.
Um,
they did manage to achieve great things together.
They built up a business.
Um,
uh,
my father made it big in the world of finance.
He always retained a kind of immigrant panic mentality.
Um,
he got,
he had us with having not had a passport for long periods of his life.
He eventually got a famous Swiss passport and he would treasure that item like
nothing else.
And every time he crossed a border,
every time he went in and out of a country,
they would be panic in his eyes as he just thought,
is this going to be the moment when they grabbed me and put me somewhere else,
et cetera.
So that was kind of part of his DNA.
So it was a foul,
I was growing up in a family that was at one level a comfortable and you know
how to add all the things in life.
At another level there was a deep psychological kind of disturbance and fear.
I would say that the dominant mood of my parents was anxiety.
And you know,
if I returned home in the evening,
they would sort of think,
oh,
you're still alive.
And I would go,
yeah,
sure,
I'm,
I'm still alive.
And they were amazed and they believe above all in hard work,
but to a slightly crazy degree.
And I as a child,
I observe them.
And I observed both their successes and their strengths and also some of their
vulnerabilities.
I realized that these were people who didn't have a very good grasp of their own
psychology.
And,
um,
they did love the arts.
Both of them loved the arts very much.
Um,
and that I inherited from them anyway.
I inherited a,
you know,
various things when always,
every,
every childhood is such as a mixed bag of,
uh,
things.
But,
um,
I came out of that childhood thinking success is important,
but at the same time,
aware enough of the limitations of success to not swallow uncritically some of
the messages about what it means to kind of make it in this world.
And so,
you know,
a lot of my work has been kind of exploring and probing what we mean by success
and the challenges it brings,
et Cetera.
So,
yeah.
I don't know if that explains some of it.
No,
no.
Does,
it adds a lot of very helpful context.
I mean,
you've written,
of course,
status anxiety,
the architecture of happiness,
the news,
a user's manual.
You,
you're prolific.
Uh,
certainly compared to me.
and,
uh,
have you,
have you developed any practices or reminders that help you to mitigate or
minimize status,
anxiety,
the keeping up with the Joneses or the fear of missing out all of these issues
that seem to really plague at least a lot of my friends and I know I,
I grappled with these,
right?
Sure.
I mean,
um,
I think,
you know,
30 vital kind of realization was it's not just me,
it's,
it's part of being alive today that we,
we,
you know,
we've got this ideology of individualism,
what,
what historians of ideas called individualism,
which is a kind of new idea because we've come from collective societies where
your sense of wellbeing did not depend on anything that you particularly did.
You,
you will first and foremost part of a tribe,
part of a village.
You were part of a family.
It,
your own achievements was only one part and perhaps even don't need the most
minor part of that other,
those other sources of identity and sense of self.
We've done away with that.
Everybody is meant to reinvent themselves.
Um,
and that's wonderful and liberating.
And,
and,
and was part of,
you know,
the European and American story in the 18th century.
But it's also deeply troubling for many of us.
It crushes us because what a burden to bear.
You know,
what,
in a way,
what unwitting cruelty to say to everyone.
You can't rely on where you have come from.
You can't define yourself by your group,
by your family,
by your ancestors,
by the nation.
You can't believe in nationalism.
It isn't enough for you to feel proud of,
you know,
your group.
You have to be proud only of yourself and what you've achieved in the years
since you finished your college education or whatever.
That is a heavy and sometimes just overwhelming button.
It's,
it's good to realize that we are under this pressure.
It's not that that will magically make that pressure disappear,
but just to,
to be able to know,
hmm,
no wonder I'm a little twitchy on evenings as the sun goes down.
No wonder that.
Get that Sunday feeling when I'm thinking my God,
I've got my dreams on the one hand and my reality on the other and the gap is
too large.
And I feel desperate,
you know,
no wonder we feel that because that is what the whole system helps us and makes
us feel,
and I don't want to say that it's all wrong,
um,
but it is certainly very demonic.
Look,
my experience of envy and status,
anxiety,
et cetera.
It's a very simple idea.
The more you know what you really want and where you're really going,
the more what everybody else is doing starts to diminish.
It's at the moments when your own path is that it's most ambiguous that the
voices of others,
the distracting chaos in which we live,
that kind of,
you know,
the,
the social media static that starts to loom large and become very threatening.
Um,
the thing about ourselves is,
as you know,
we're not very good at understanding what it is that we really want.
We're extremely prone to latch on to suggestions from the outside world.
You know,
like,
you know,
when every,
when everybody was saying,
you know,
tech was big,
a lot of people who never thought about it thought tech was really for them.
Uh,
when banking was big,
people thought banking's you know,
for me,
when people tell you,
telling you that,
you know,
romantic love is perfect,
you think,
well,
I must be finding an perhaps even feeling romantic love,
et cetera.
So we've got a lot of models out there that don't necessarily suit us but a
deeply powerful and I think that could to calm down.
First of all,
you know,
you have to realize that your ultimate responsibility is to yourself,
not the neighbors,
not your parents.
I'm not the expectations that were put upon you.
This is where the thought of death is tremendously releasing that your only real
responsibility is to,
uh,
you know,
yourself as a kind of mortal,
very temporary being a constellation of,
uh,
you know,
particles and proteins that are hanging together in a particular shape for a few
years before disappearing forever.
That's you.
Um,
and there are more ways to be then you know,
your college,
um,
you know,
graduation,
speech led you to think.
Um,
so yeah,
these are some of the tensions of the modern,
modern soul.
And I,
I found a lot of,
this is something I sometimes have trouble,
uh,
verbalizing to people,
but I find that a lot of Buddhist thought has parallels with,
with stoic thought in terms of whether it's Marcus really a saying at the end
of,
uh,
at the end of a very short period of time,
I will be bones and dust on the ground and that's is like upload lifting note to
himself in his journal before he goes off to battle.
Or it's like a Musashi Miyamoto who is one of the one of,
if not the most famous swordsmen and Japanese history who would say probably
more or less the exact same thing before setting off on his day.
And it sounds very depressing and it sounds like a downer,
but it's,
it for me has been such a helpful reminder and it's,
it's,
um,
sad circumstances,
but I've had two friends die of unexpected causes very suddenly in the last
month.
And it just,
it,
it seems to be all the more important that we have some type of Memento Mori,
right?
Some type of reminder of death that,
uh,
and in fact I have a friend who is in finance.
Don't hold that against him.
He's a good guy.
Uh,
but uh,
he has a,
an excel spreadsheet that calculates and display is on his desk,
the number of expected hours he has left in his life so that he sees that
everyday.
I don't have that.
But in the,
for instance,
the four hour chef and the author photograph,
I've put a small skull in the very bottom corner.
It's kind of hard to see,
but that's what a lot of artists use to do.
Not to say that I'm an artist,
but that was one of the ways I wanted to constantly remind myself that time is
of time can be very short.
You don't,
you don't know how much,
how many hours you have left on the planet.
Um,
where do you,
I'm sorry,
I was just going to ask and feel free to,
to take this in a different direction,
but with the,
the recognizing that the clearer you have defined what you want,
the less fear of missing out,
the less status anxiety,
the less suggestive you will be to the,
the,
the madness of the mob.
Uh,
where would,
what do you,
where do you want to be in three years time,
for instance?
Like what,
uh,
what would you like your sort of day to day existence to be like,
or what would you like to have achieved?
It doesn't have to be professional,
uh,
in the next [inaudible].
Well,
I mean,
if I can mention that the professional,
one of the things that's been really absorbing me in the last few years is,
um,
well I was a writer for most of my professional life and then I always had a
sense that writing books wasn't quite enough.
And what I mean by an office,
I didn't feel that sending people,
you know,
200 pages glued together was necessarily always going to be the solution to many
of the issues that I cared about.
I felt I sort of crisis of the soul where I realized that,
you know,
this idea of being a writer that I'd want it so badly when I was younger,
um,
was no longer fully satisfying me because I realized that so many problems,
we're not going to be amenable to treatment by books that you needed other
things.
Um,
and that led me to begin an organization,
um,
which I called the school of life,
which was very much in line with things that,
uh,
I've been caring about it in my books for a long time.
But there were a few differences for a start.
It wasn't just about me.
Um,
it was actually about gathering,
gathering together with a group of likeminded,
but,
but different people with different talents and different skills and starting
something that,
um,
you know,
could be a proper collective and an institution.
The reason I started where I did was that I read a lot about religion because at
a certain point in my kind of crisis about,
you know,
the meaning of being a writer,
et cetera.
I got very interested in religions cause I thought religion,
I'm an atheist,
I don't believe,
but I'm very interested in religions and very sympathetic to many of the things
you find in religion.
And what I realized that you find in religion is a machine organization.
Religions don't just believe in writing their deepest thoughts down in a book
and that's it.
They support things by having communal activities,
group activities.
I'm getting very involved in the arts getting involved in this thing which we
call ritual.
I mean we can talk more about that and what is a ritual but ritualized actions,
repetition,
the repetition of ideas,
not just,
you don't just read them once you repeat them,
maybe with other people.
Um,
uh,
you,
you might use music to,
to get a point across.
All of these things fascinated me.
And I realized that as religion declined in,
you know,
in Europe in the 19th century,
in many parts of the United States,
even now,
et Cetera,
um,
as religion disappeared,
it was in many places,
uh,
replaced by culture that,
you know,
people who in previous agents would have been religious.
I've got very interested in music and literature and philosophy and all these
sort of things.
Um,
but I realized that those things were missing.
One thing that religion really did well,
which was the kind of the group bit,
the institutional bet,
the embedding in daily life bit.
And I thought,
couldn't we do some of that now?
And I also look backwards to ancient Greece and I realized that philosophers,
many of them,
it started up schools.
Epicurus it started a school called the garden.
The stoics have,
you know,
the stower Plato,
uh,
had,
the,
um,
uh,
at his school,
the academy,
et Cetera.
And um,
it's not that I wanted to directly imitate that,
but I thought,
how interesting that these were people who thought you,
it isn't enough just to be you.
And a book.
Anyway,
many of these sorts of contributed to my beginning,
this thing that I called the school of life and it's been the focus of a lot of
my energy in the last four years.
Um,
it's give you just a sense of it.
This thing has its HQ in London,
but we now have 10 branches around the world,
including in Australia and the far east and Europe,
et Cetera.
I'm not in the United States yet,
but what we do is,
um,
we don't,
we don't care about that.
No,
we just want a big,
bigger cars cause you can't so much.
But know I can explain why we're not in the United States.
Cause I did,
I tell you,
I love,
love to be one day,
but we're not.
Anyway,
we um,
uh,
we run classes,
we publish books,
we put on a fence,
uh,
we run a youtube channel.
Uh,
we do all sorts of things and um,
and it's just,
you have some great,
great videos on these.
I highly recommend it.
Thank you.
And you know,
really what will,
what we're trying to do is to take a lot of the stuff that I care about but,
but try and find other channels stanwich to distributed,
I mean,
your career more than anyone shows you know,
how that can be done and that is done.
And so I felt a kind of restlessness,
which perhaps you felt as well as at a certain point about,
you know,
what it means to be a writer and,
um,
and it's perhaps an intersection of writing and business for me and,
and,
uh,
learning how to create a business out of something that might previously have
just been seen as a kind of romantic inspiration of the kind of lone artist.
Um,
and all of that's been very interesting.
And,
and you know,
you ask about the goals in the next few years.
I really hope to continue to make a contribution there and to make school of
life as good as it can be for us to touch as many lives as we can in as diverse
away as we can,
um,
to,
to invite more and more people into this kind of little whom we built.
And,
uh,
that was started in 2008.
Just that,
right?
Or was it 2008?
Yes,
yes.
That's,
that is around the time 2008,
2009,
uh,
after,
I think partially instigated by the cultural,
uh,
well I shouldn't say cultural existential and financial insecurity caused by
the,
uh,
mortgage backed securities crisis of that time.
But I developed a quite a high degree of restlessness about being an author,
which led to starting the angel investing and looking at startups as a way to,
um,
using as a means of leverage.
So using startups as an Archimedes lever of sorts to translate some of these
concepts into the real world in a way that could scale at a very high level.
Uh,
but let me ask you a slightly more personal question.
So what's,
for instance,
bad habits are you working to overcome at the moment where I hope to work on?
Let them,
let's look at the present day.
I have a million of my own that I usually overshare in Facebook Q and A's and
things like that,
especially if wine is involved.
But uh,
what,
what bad habits are you currently working on?
Um,
look,
it's a very classic one that,
that you know,
so many people,
so many of us are guilty of which is not properly communicating.
And what I mean by properly is not properly teaching others about myself,
what I'm feeling,
what I would like,
what bothers me.
And instead of properly communicating,
merely acting out and symbolizing things and expecting to be understood.
And this is a constant effort really to,
um,
to not imagine that those around me should mind read.
They can't know what I feel unless I tell them.
And also they won't hear me unless I speak in a certain way.
Um,
if I'm agitated and get annoyed quickly,
that immediately shuts off communication.
If I blame them,
that shuts off communication.
They will not hear if I humiliate anyone that that message will get lost.
So if you're trying to get something across in a resist,
all those bad habits that we all have around communication,
I think it's trying to learn how to be a better teacher and a better student.
You know,
teaching has these sort of weird connotations.
You think of like some guy teaching history in a high school or something of
that.
But in order to have a good life,
all of us need to learn how to be good teachers and good students of one
another.
Because every day creates moments when we need to teach something,
we need to give somebody a lesson.
It may be in,
you know,
what time we're going to be home tonight or how we're feeling about,
um,
you know,
some events on the horizon or whatever it is.
But we're going to need to get something across.
And that requires kind of rules and disciplines and just simply blurting it out
simply kind of exploding in some way or emoting in some way is normally the
worst way.
And at the same time we have to learn to become students,
which is to listen properly,
to interpret.
It may be somebody who's making a bit of a mess of trying to tell you something,
but try and listen to what they might be telling you beneath the surface.
I've got relatively small kids.
They very often don't tell you what they feel.
They can't tell you directly what they feel.
You have to do some guesswork and a lot of what you have to deduce the juice.
But I think,
I think you have to deduce from everybody's,
uh,
say and you know,
very few of us learn on the spot.
You know,
if,
if somebody told me or told you a big central truth about you,
you know,
the thing about you,
he is the editor.
Or the thing about you,
us is that data.
If that was said even just vaguely,
brutally,
or,
or just even with the little whatever,
we would shut down.
We get defensive.
We go,
no,
that's not true.
How do you know?
What are you trying to do?
Et cetera.
We shut down quickly.
We don't absorb that information.
And we should,
we should try and get less defensive.
And at the same time when we're in the kind of giving feedback role,
we should really think carefully.
So I think this whole business of listening and feedback is a,
is a key issue that I'm,
I'm,
I'm always trying to work on,
I'm trying to do the same thing.
And that was,
that was my newly adopted puppy off to try to make his feelings known,
to dry,
to trying to communicate a,
I've taught her to kick the bells on the door.
But aside from
that,
I'm so far failing it at speaking dog,
but the,
uh,
I'm trying to do the same thing.
And I think that,
uh,
you mentioned the young children.
I think if you,
if you could,
you can recognize that if you,
uh,
if you were to keep someone from having lunch,
keep anyone from having lunch for three or four hours and uh,
give them,
uh,
an argument with a spouse or loved one,
our coworker 60 minutes earlier,
that their emotional state will probably be closer to your children than
anything else.
And if you assume that when you read their email as opposed to a reading
malicious intent?
I was always,
uh,
I shouldn't say always.
I was told quite some time ago something that I've,
I've enjoyed trying to remind myself up so I don't respond in kind so I don't
volley back something nasty with something nasty that uh,
don't attribute to malice what you can attribute to incompetence.
Nice.
And a close,
a close cousin of that,
which I've had to add to it is don't attribute to malice what you can attribute
to in competence or,
yes,
I often think someone wants to this to me and I,
it's really stuck in my mind that when people seem like they are mean,
that almost never mean that anxious.
That's what,
that's what inspires the behavior.
That's good.
Read as meanness.
But it very frequently is not meanness.
And these are very basic bits of psychology.
But you know,
I should say it again.
The older I get,
the more I think we are relatively simple creatures just as you know,
to nourish us physically.
We need basic things,
some breads or you know,
an all level to some water.
And off we go.
So when it comes to our kind of inner psyches,
um,
many of the things that we need have an almost breathtaking simplicity.
It is things like the person is mean not worthy,
almost mantras.
They are simple things.
And I think we are so highly educated.
We overeducate ourselves out of connection with these simple truths.
Um,
and they are so key.
And this is something you mentioned Buddhism,
this is something the Zen Buddhists are very keen on is Zen Buddhist philosophy.
And poetry is often unbelievably simple.
[inaudible] you ear rather than seeing that as an argument against it.
Um,
you know,
the great masters will ponder a sentence,
turn it over,
write it down in ever more,
you know,
beautiful,
refined,
but simple ways on a piece of paper,
et Cetera.
And,
and I think that we've got,
unfortunately,
because of science and the Glamor of science,
this addiction to the idea that the most valuable things must be very
complicated and constantly new rather than perhaps very simple and repetitions
of some basic,
quite old truths.
And it's just what I think we're mixing up a,
a kind of source of wisdom in one area,
which is,
you know,
flying rockets with,
uh,
a source of wisdom in and other is like how to get through your day.
And we're,
we've misinterpreting what we need for both realms.
We're thinking we need to kind of scientific version in personal life where
actually it's really super unhelpful.
Yeah.
I think also we tend to,
as a higher primates with big prefrontal cortex is,
uh,
cortices.
I have no idea.
In any case,
we want to,
uh,
if we're having a bad day,
we look at these big existential questions as opposed to,
did I have five alos or should I have $5?
Maybe my blood sugar is just low or just right.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I love that it wasn't it Clinton who said that,
uh,
you know,
before when dealing with anyone who upset,
he always asks,
has this person slept?
Have they eaten?
You know,
it's somebody else bugging them.
He goes through this kind of simple checklists.
But we are,
you know,
we know so much when we're handling babies and the baby is kicking and crying.
We almost never,
one never does one say,
you know,
that babies out to get me or you know,
she's got evil intentions.
We go,
you know,
she's probably tired or he's,
he hasn't had enough sleep or maybe it's too tight around his collar or
whatever.
We look for pretty benevolent,
often pretty basic explanations when once we reach adulthood,
we almost never,
I mean,
when have we been in a situation with an angry person who's,
you know,
whatever,
we always look at it at the intellectual level.
We very rarely go,
wow,
this is probably someone who's really pretty tired or,
you know,
it's uh,
it's one o'clock and they've not had anything to eat.
So that's where the explanation of it,
it offends ourself knowledge.
It offends or a sense of dignity,
but it really shouldn't.
And as you say,
we are a,
you know,
an amazing computer sitting on some very,
very basic bits of,
of,
of software and not to accept how basic we are is its own version of kind of
pretension and,
and,
and we should resist it.
And self sabotage.
Uh,
for sure.
I would love to shift gears a little bit and a lob some rapid fire questions
your way.
The answers don't need to be rapid,
but,
uh,
when you think of the word successful,
who is the first person who comes to mind and why?
I didn't want it,
but,
um,
but unfortunately the Steve jobs came to mind and I'm really annoyed about that
because I don't actually see,
see him as,
as the quintessence of,
of success.
Um,
look,
I think a successful person is somebody who has taken hold and fathoms that
talent made the most out of those talents and reconcile themselves to their
weaknesses.
They're not ranting and raving about their weaknesses.
They have a sense of what those weaknesses are.
They're not blaming the world for them.
They know them,
they own them at the same time.
Uh,
they,
they've had a sense of their strengths and they've been able to make something
off those strengths and maybe that things relatively modest,
but they've still managed to externalize those strengths.
That's asking a lot that is a successful life.
Very few of us are lucky enough to get there.
Um,
but I think that's what it might be.
Who,
who would be a someone not Steve Jobs,
who certainly was Brenda ranting and raving and I'm not sure how aware he was of
any of his weaknesses,
but uh,
who,
who would be an exemplar of that for you?
It's funny,
I've,
I was recently in,
in Switzerland where I come from and when I was little I was partly brought up
by my parents but also pop also partly brought up by very kindly lady who lived
with us in the,
in the family.
She was helping the family.
It's a trend.
She was almost like a second mother to me and she's now 83 years old.
And lives in an isolated Swiss village.
She's in amazing health for her age.
And she is a true saint in,
she's not religious.
But you know,
if you wanted to offer somebody up to science as somebody who is well balanced,
you weren't read about or in the newspaper,
you won't,
you know,
sea bass,
cetera.
But you actually sit in her kitchen and you talk about politics with her.
You talk about child raising,
you talk about the meaning of life.
This is a person with an inherent ballast who's no nonsense,
who knows how to be kind,
who knows how to laugh,
who knows.
It's such a,
and you know,
the world is full of such people,
people who represent what you might call an ordinary genius,
an ordinary genius or the business of living like that.
And,
and we,
we,
we walk past these people because they don't star in any of our,
you know,
uh,
calendars I had to go so far as to say that perhaps a few more of them are women
than men.
Um,
and,
uh,
they are utterly unheralded.
Uh,
but,
but they are out there and they are the true philosophers.
Yeah.
I guess that can be contrasted with the extra ordinary hubris that we seem to
worship.
Uh,
oftentimes sensory.
That's right.
I mean that,
that,
that's why I was kicking myself when,
you know,
the very word successes become contaminated by our ideas off someone
extraordinary,
very rich cetera.
And,
um,
and that's really unhelpful,
that ultimately to be properly successful is,
you know,
to be at peace as well.
You know,
I've seen too many people who were circled successful who are not at peace and,
um,
you know,
that's a problem.
Well then,
and not to be too cliched about it,
but I think that it's easy to define success as a,
is getting what you want.
But for those people you mentioned with that internal ballast,
that ordinary genius,
they also want what they have.
Right.
They appreciate what they have,
which I think is a not nearly as taught or studied as the achieving of what we
want.
Absolutely.
And I,
you know,
you say taught,
I mean,
we need reminders of this.
That's,
you know,
we're otherwise people go,
oh yeah,
you know,
when you tell someone that they go,
Oh yeah,
that's office.
I knew that.
And you go,
yeah,
but is it alive is such a difference between an idea being in theory in your
brain and alive in your brain.
And those kinds of ideas about appreciating everyday such are generally not
alive in our brains.
And that's a problem of art really.
They're not artistically alive.
And,
um,
that's something to bear in mind.
What is the book that you've given most as a gift aside from your own?
Well,
there was a stage,
um,
before I got married and when I was on the dating scene,
when I gave a lot of copies,
this was the 90s,
I gave a lot of copies of Milan Kundera to people.
It,
it suggested the unbearable lightness of being was a,
a book that I gave out a lot.
Um,
I don't know if I still would,
but I do admire this check writer very much and um,
and,
and it has all kinds of wisdom and um,
and it's beautifully written and impactful as well.
I've given quite a lot of copies of Martine's essays to people down the years.
Um,
and um,
I've not given Proust cause it's a little heavy.
Um,
but yes,
that,
that kind of thing.
Thank you.
And for those people,
we're,
his name has come up a bit,
uh,
or,
or several times in this conversation Montaine there's a,
there's a post by Ryan holiday,
then introduction to Monte [inaudible] on the blog.
For those of you want to check it out@fourhourworkweek.com and I'm sure that
will be linked to in the show notes as well as everything that we've talked
about so far.
What is something you believe that other people think is insane
or many other people?
Doesn't have to be everyone,
but what is something you think that most other people think?
Yeah,
I believe in the nanny state.
We live in a very,
you have to,
you have that expression in the states,
right?
The nanny state?
Yes.
So I believe in the nanny state.
Um,
I'm not coming at it from the left or the right.
It's almost,
you know,
irrespective of that.
But I believe in essentially in a public sphere,
which should offer guidance.
I think the idea of the neutral public sphere where,
for example,
um,
it's just completely left to the market to decide,
you know,
and if you've got the money,
you buy an advertisement,
you know,
if,
if you,
if you want to pay for a billboard,
pay for a billboard,
et Cetera.
Um,
and I think that,
you know,
I'm,
I'm interested in the way that we went from religious societies,
which guided people towards important truths to assist to societies that have
just left everyone completely alone.
So in my utopia,
um,
there would be a lot more guidance.
Um,
I,
I am a believer in because I've needed so much guidance.
Um,
I would,
I would be really,
I would pay real attention to what's on the airwaves,
for example.
Um,
in UK at the moment where I'm based,
um,
the government is thinking hard about what it should do with it's gigantic
television station,
the BBC,
that it gives millions,
in fact,
billions of pounds to every year.
And it's wondering what it should do with it.
And the argument seems to be,
seems to be quite a sterile one,
but my view should be on the national broadcaster,
should be programs that systematically address all the largest failings and
dilemmas of the nation,
including for the failures of pet around parenting,
around a family,
breakdowns,
around violence,
around anxiety,
around a loneliness,
et cetera.
We know government statistician's know what the problems are in,
you know,
large populations,
but we,
they refuse the tools that they have like say the BBC and the idea is we'll,
no one should tell anyone how to live as such a fear of fascism,
communism.
Um,
and I can't help thinking that we have made a bogey man here,
that that isn't really the threat.
The real threat is that we are drowning in chaotic noise and unable to find a
kind of balance.
Um,
and I think that,
um,
you know,
I'd be up for a little bit more vigilant about that and a little bit more
nannying of the best kind.
So that's the kind of thing that I'm very careful not to tell you.
I don't know why I've told you and your millions of listeners now,
but,
but I,
you know,
I,
I'm aware,
you know,
cause I,
I use youtube a lot and I'm aware that if you,
if you put anything out there that says even anything like that and unbelievable
turn of messages come through along the lines of you're a communist or you're a
fascist or um,
you're trying to infantilize me or blah blah,
blah.
And my view was always hang on a minute,
you know,
we're all adults and when you know you're an adult,
you can also admit that actually seeking help,
therapeutic help in a broader sense is part of adult life.
That saying,
you know,
no one teaches me anything.
I'm just my own person totally.
Uh,
is a kind of slightly brittle version of maturity.
And I'm interested in a more dependent relationship on others where we can seek
help where we're not offended if someone offers help to us because we can turn
it away.
But we're not offended by the offer of help.
And so these are some of the things that I think about late at night.
And it would offend and frighten everybody.
So a couple of,
a couple of thoughts.
The first is,
uh,
on the art of asking,
I think Amanda Palmer,
the musician has a lot of interesting things to say that,
uh,
people could benefit from,
from checking out.
The second is on the,
uh,
being called a fascist.
I think that Youtube,
I love,
God bless it,
but if you scroll to page four or five of comments,
I think on any video,
even if it's kitten playing the piano,
you're going to have Hitler and fascism in there somewhere.
Uh,
the,
uh,
then the third piece I would say is in terms of this,
the,
the state or the government offering guidance or maybe even differing positions
on some of these bigger moral questions in life questions,
I think that there might be a forcing function and that forcing function,
uh,
could be artificial intelligence and things like autonomous cars.
I think technology,
oddly enough,
the most cutting edge technology is going to drive a reversion in some ways or
return to some of the oldest philosophical quandaries and thought experiments,
uh,
that,
that we have that we,
that we visit and say a freshmen seminar.
And to think of as irrelevant like a,
you know,
the trolley scenario or the fat man blocking the cave with four people inside
who are going to starve.
But when you translate that to modern day,
I mean even right now there are tech companies hiring,
uh,
what they might consider utilitarian philosophers like the,
um,
along the lines of Saint Peter Singer,
uh,
to advise them on some of these questions.
For instance,
if you have to program a car that is going to make decisions in a disaster
scenarios like,
uh,
there's,
there is something in the middle of the road I have to swerve.
Do I choose to hit the six old ladies on the right hand side or the to school
children on the left side?
How do you make that calculus?
And so I think that in in some ways technology might force the states,
uh,
or,
or governments of various types to take a more active role in this type of,
yeah,
I
say should because I think that's absolutely right and fascinating.
And I too have been very interested in,
in artificial intelligence of late,
and I think that,
um,
what we're talking about is the broad recognition that we are not very good at
making decisions.
That our brains are extremely faulty and all sorts of ways.
At the same time we have this idea that no one should tell us how to live and
what can slightly break the log jam is big data,
scientific information.
So that in the Google of,
you know,
in 50 years time you will say,
who should I marry?
And the answers will really be quite accurate and personally attuned to you and
akin to having gone to psychotherapy for 10 years in their level of awareness
of,
you know,
the issues facing you.
Um,
so I think you're absolutely right that artificial intelligence will,
um,
breakthrough many people's resistance to insights,
which currently,
because they're not based on science and hard data seem,
I just too vulnerable to being shot down by the,
by the kind of line of,
you know,
who are you to say it doesn't have any fact behind it.
Uh,
they may be right,
but because,
because we,
we live in a society that's quite obsessed by science and facts and won't accept
things unless they're backed up by facts and says,
we may just need to wait a little until some of these more humanistic truths and
insights of got the backing that is required to,
to allow them to have sort of mass uptake.
Oh,
agreed.
And I think that,
uh,
another,
another factor will,
will sort of drive together in confluence,
certainly with other things,
uh,
to AI or incorporating AI.
And that is virtual reality.
I just had a,
I was not a true believer until,
uh,
less than a week ago.
I had a virtual reality demo that I can't go into too many details about because
it's not hugely public.
That completely blew my mind.
I mean,
the experience was so lifelike and so compelling that it made me wonder,
uh,
more than ever if we're in a Similac room of our own,
of some type,
but it will raise questions such as,
I mean,
when you are in a three dimensional immersive photorealistic environment and
most certainly there will be a tactile components and so on all factory
components,
the,
those will come at some point when we'll gains the permitted for instance,
that rather than being relegated to a two d surface on the television,
allow you to kill someone,
blood bludgeon,
someone to death,
uh,
or I mean much worse,
right?
The,
are those going to be in any way regulated or are those going to be allowed,
you know,
and what effect does that have versus a more video game asking the traditional
sense experience,
right.
Said it's scary,
it's very terrifying,
but at the same time I think holds a lot of promise.
Um,
let me,
I'm completely abruptly transition to another short question,
which is,
uh,
what is your favorite dot documentary or movie?
Well,
what are,
what are some of your favorite document?
Well,
I very much enjoyed the documentary,
which I don't know if you'll Nichols seven up,
which was done in the UK.
Um,
and what it did is it followed a group of children every seven years starting
from their seventh birthday.
And these children were,
um,
picked deliberately from wide variety of social backgrounds,
different kinds of families,
et cetera.
And every seven years these kids were revisited and we traced their lives.
And of course know this is one of the things that art can do for us.
It kind of traces lives over time spans that we normally can't have access to.
So,
um,
now these people are in their 50s and they're still making the documentary.
Um,
and uh,
and it gets updated every seven years,
every seven years.
There's a new thing and it's a kind of,
it's a weird feature of British life,
like everyone knows [inaudible] sort of thing.
Uh,
and it just comes along every year,
every seven years.
And we know these people and their lives show such a variation,
ups and downs and sometimes,
you know,
sometimes things are going really well,
are the times getting terribly et cetera.
And again,
it's so much the art I like,
it's,
it's very much a tune to the every day it's concerned with broadly speaking with
wisdom and how we can live and very undramatic but quiet be so powerful.
It's for my money.
It's probably the best documentary that exists.
I've very much recommended.
Um,
so the house
it comes to mind is a strong endorsement and I'll have to,
I will,
uh,
I'm on a tear with doc,
so I'll have to check this out.
The,
uh,
what is a purchase of $100 or less that has positively impacted your life in the
last six months?
Um,
I've really discovered that pomegranate and the pop pop,
it's just a weird thing.
I never even knew they existed.
Really.
I knew the word.
I just know what it was.
Anyway.
Uh,
someone told me about pomegranates and that they could be really interesting
thing to eat and make part of one's diet.
And,
um,
it's,
it's a thing I now regularly have a,
they're not cheap.
Each one is,
it's a few pounds and,
um,
but the,
the delicious,
the weird and um,
you know,
you'd think,
wow,
you know,
it's,
it's great.
This kind of thing exists on this,
on this little blue dot.
Um,
this app,
this thing grows.
So that's,
that's brought me constant,
constant pleasure upon the life of pomegranates.
How do you,
how do you consume your pelvic granites?
What is your preferred sort of method and,
and,
uh,
time for politics
them in half.
And then while you've got your hand with your fingers slightly open over the
pomegranate face,
down into the palm of your hand,
you then strike the primer granite hard with a wooden spoon,
which gets the seeds to shake out.
They go into a little bowl.
Um,
that's a good trick.
Yeah.
You hit it a few times and now they fall.
And,
um,
and it's just a,
it makes a delicious kind of snack.
And,
and you feel good and you feel virtuous,
but it's,
it's nice as well.
Um,
so I really recommend that I'd,
I think all in my ideal nanny states,
um,
you know,
there would be pomegranates in every poll,
every pomegranate rat ranch and right.
They would,
they would be forcibly on sale in every gas station across the United States.
And I think,
I think genuinely the health,
but more importantly,
the happiness of would rise exponentially.
I love it.
Uh,
what I used to love eating grapefruits in the morning.
My grandmother used to use to use brown sugar on sort of precut grapefruits that
we could scoop out with special grapefruit spoons.
So that,
that,
that this is,
this is making me long DNA.
Uh,
what's,
um,
what rituals,
you mentioned rituals earlier,
what rituals are important,
uh,
for you on a daily basis.
Um,
my,
the listeners often like evening,
I'm sorry,
morning routines,
but it doesn't have to be morning.
What,
what rituals or routines do you find very valuable,
important?
Well,
you know,
there was a lot of talk a few years ago and still now for meditation and
mindfulness and getting into a southern state.
And um,
and I,
I thought a lot about this and I thought,
why is it that it's not quite working for me as it's defined,
but that there's something here that I really like and I realized that what I
love doing at the end of the day,
or the beginning of the day is to kind of download my brain,
is to just download those thoughts that are buzzing around slightly,
shapeless,
slightly directionless,
and they need a little help.
And if I don't get to grips with them,
they will disturb my sleep will,
they'll wake me up early.
So what I like to do is just sit with a pad and paper and write down in very
small,
slightly scrolly,
illegible handwriting,
lots of things.
It could just be a word,
an image of something and they will be the starting points of things.
You know,
books have began out of one word that I'd sort of caught in my,
and it's a,
it's a kind of housekeeping,
it's a kind of intellectual housekeeping.
I'd like to call it a kind of philosophical meditation where you just,
yeah,
you just turn over what's going on in your mind.
And I think insomnia,
I went through a stage of having insomnia and I think that insomnia is a kind of
revenge.
All the stuff that you haven't thought about enough that's demands to be thought
about.
And we'll wake you up in order that it gets it's Fascia of,
of thought.
And if you can do that before bed,
um,
with a pattern paper,
it can be,
you know,
the best,
uh,
you know,
sleeping pill you've,
you've ever had.
Do you have a particular type of journal or pad that you'd like to,
I'm unfussy,
I'm pretty unfussy about what I write on all kinds of,
of pads.
Um,
I have a,
a wonderful Japanese pen call,
a pilot,
you know,
there's pilot pens and it's called a g tech c four.
And I write religiously only with those.
I'm also very,
I'm the last person on the planet to work with a blackberry and I write all
sorts of thoughts down on a blackberry.
Um,
uh,
and,
and that's very helpful too.
So those are my tools.
So you share the,
the
sort of this digital blackberry in common with a friend of mine named Neil
Strauss is written seven or eight times best sell on it.
It's an odd feeling.
You feel very left out and there should be a support group started because it's
a,
it's a very isolated position to be in.
And one questions,
one,
so insanity.
Sometimes one thinks one we'll go over to the light side soon,
but one just can't do it.
And,
and yeah,
and we are,
uh,
if you could have just a few more questions,
if you could have one billboard anywhere with anything on it,
what would it say?
Um,
well I think it would,
it would probably pick up on the need to appreciate the need to be kind.
Um,
I mean it could be,
it could be something stock.
I mean,
it sums up what we were saying.
It could,
it could say you have only,
you know,
an average life is however,
how many,
how many hundred thousands of hours,
you know,
there's bigger,
oh,
I,
you know,
I maybe if I were a better caffeinated,
well what if he is that good life is okay.
It would say life is only 400,000 hours long be kind or something like that.
Just to grab the motorist as that speeding down the highway at insane speed up.
I like it.
And what advice would you give your 30 year old self?
Um,
calm down and [inaudible] where would you be at 30.
What uh,
what's the sort of surrounding context?
Um,
what was it or what should it be?
No,
no,
no.
Where were you,
where were,
where were you in,
I mean 30 was a,
it was a weird year.
Um,
my father died when I was 30,
very surprisingly.
So I was suddenly in a,
in a kind of different,
different place and that was very shocking.
At the same time.
It was a very successful year.
Might my book the constellations for us,
we came out,
um,
I,
I met my wife,
my,
she wasn't then my wife,
but I met the person who became my wife that year.
So it was a kind of,
um,
a year of many things.
I mean,
I think,
I think I would have also said,
you know,
appreciate what's good about this moment.
Um,
don't always think that you're,
you know,
you're on a permanent journey in a stop and enjoy the view.
Um,
this is life too.
I think it,
it took me a long time to kind of dare to appreciate the moment because I always
had this assumption that if you appreciate the moment you're weakening your
resolve to improve your circumstances,
that's not true.
But I think when you're young,
it's sort of associated with that.
And even I think,
I like flowers.
You see,
I had people around me,
he would say things like,
well,
isn't that flour nice?
And a little part of me was thinking,
you absolute loser.
You've taken time to appreciate a flower.
Do you not have bigger plans?
I mean,
is this,
is this the limit of your ambition?
Um,
and it's,
you know,
when life knocked you around a bit,
when you've seen a few things and it's time has happened and you've got some
under your belt,
you think you start to think more highly of,
of modest things like,
like flowers and pretty sky and well,
just a morning when nothing's gone wrong and everyone's been pretty nice to
everyone else and things are pretty nice and it's,
you know,
it's coming up to 11 o'clock or 12 o'clock and things,
things are going well and you think that's nice.
No one's died.
No one,
everyone's okay.
Um,
it makes you a little bit more modest.
And I didn't have that at all at 30 and I think it was a kind of,
when people talk about their young people being ungrateful,
you often go low.
How do you mean that ungrateful?
It's not an,
it's not in gratitude.
It's anxiety again,
but,
but I wished that I could have reassured my,
my anxious self and,
and,
and just said,
you know,
that there is time to look out of the window.
And,
and spotters flowers.
That's great advice.
It's advice I need to take to heart.
Also.
I think I've,
I've done better.
Uh,
it's funny you mentioned flowers because specifically when I go on walks,
I make a point,
says thanks to my girlfriend to stop and smell flowers,
whether it's with the dog or otherwise,
just as a brief pause.
But,
um,
I think that,
you know,
ambition can be a wonderful tool,
but it's a terrible master and it's also something that for the most part,
you cash in,
in the future and the future may not come as we know the exactly,
exactly.
It.
And it reminds me of this story that a Neil Gaiman the writer tells,
I think it might've been in his commencement speech making good art,
which everyone should watch.
You just Google it.
But,
uh,
he said he,
he was reflecting on a signing books for Sandman,
which was his,
his first real huge hit and signing comic books in this case.
And,
uh,
Stephen King,
I believe it was said,
you know,
enjoy this moment.
And he did.
He was,
he was,
he was wrapped up in,
I can only imagine looking two years in the future,
three years in the future,
striking while the iron is hot,
whatever it might've been.
And I think that's something that,
uh,
that I need a constant reminder of.
Uh,
and the journaling,
as you mentioned,
I think also helps with
if there's a funny thing,
my wife and I,
she spotted that I kept talking about cancer and you know,
kept saying things like,
well,
I don't have cancer yet.
And you know,
I'm,
if one day I get cancer,
and so when we now have this joke between us,
because this,
I kept putting it like this.
And so now she goes,
remember we're in the years before your bowel cancer.
And it's just,
that's just partly teasing me and she's kind of a,
but really what we're saying,
you know,
she goes,
remember it's before the bowel cancer.
Um,
and it's really a way of saying kind of my God,
you know,
things can get very miserable,
um,
very quickly.
It only takes a very few cells to sub divide in the wrong way.
And a lot of what seems important now,
we'll just no longer be.
And yeah,
we just have to keep that in mind all the time.
These today,
which seems so incomplete from so many ways and you know,
maybe frustrating and this and that way today may be the day that,
you know,
in a week you will look back on as paradise.
Um,
because we are so it could always get so much worse.
And I think partly it's having children as well.
You know,
we're very much at the mercy of fortune,
you know,
stoics talked a lot about fortune,
fortune can do anything with us.
You know,
we are very fragile creatures.
Yearning is a tap us or hit us in slightly the wrong place and we are done for,
and the kind of levels of tragedy that can be,
you know,
all of us,
you only,
you'd have to push us a little bit and we crack very easily,
whether that's,
you know,
the pressure of disgrace or physical illness or financial pressure that it
doesn't take very much.
And,
um,
yeah.
So we do have to appreciate every day that goes by without a major disaster.
I think that's a great,
great place to wrap up.
Uh,
I love your work.
Where can people find out about what you're up to online,
find you on social,
et Cetera?
How can they say hello?
What would you like them to check out of yours first,
Brian,
if they're unfamiliar with your work?
Well,
they can come and see my website,
which is my name,
[inaudible] dot com they can come and see me at [inaudible] on Twitter,
just at Orlando bottle.
Um,
I run a youtube channel via the school of life.
So come and check out the school of life@schooloflife.com and come and look at
some of the films that I make that I make.
I make three films a week,
so there's a lot of stuff out there.
I write a blog,
it's something called the book of life.org.
Um,
so you'll see a lot of my pieces on all sorts of things.
So take a look around.
There's quite a lot in the,
in the digital space.
And it's quite a lot that's free.
And if you want to buy a book while Amazon has them all and all the big,
big stores too.
So,
um,
yeah,
that's,
that's me.
And out there in the world.
If you could recommend a one video and one piece of writing of yours to start
with,
what would you suggest?
Um,
well if we're talking about,
uh,
um,
we were talking a lot about Proust.
Um,
actually no,
now let me recommend something else.
There's a film on my youtube channel called higher consciousness.
Is there any discussion of this strange terms and has got about higher
consciousness?
What is it,
what does it mean to achieve higher consciousness?
So Punch into,
uh,
to,
um,
to the school of life,
Youtube Channel,
punch in higher consciousness and you'll get this film about,
I dunno,
how to look at the world in,
you know,
with a higher consciousness.
And then if you want to read something,
go and check out how Proust can change your life.
Um,
I think it's still,
it's a book that's still holds up after all these years and um,
it's got a lot of things that I deeply believe in,
so,
so check that out.
Wonderful.
Well I really admire your work.
I enjoy your work and I would love for you to continue doing your work before
the bowel cancer of course.
And I really appreciate you taking some time and if you're,
you're an incredibly generous host person and an incredibly gifted
communicators,
speaker,
writer inspire us.
So it's been a tremendous honor for me.
Thank you so much.
I'm,
I know you've,
you've done me a serious service and doing this and I fully recognize it.
Bowel cancer were no bowel cancer.
It's fantastic.
This has been,
this has been really fun and everybody out there,
everything we talked about and you will be able to find in the show notes that
is that four hour workweek.com all spelled out.
Click on podcast and you can find this and all previous episodes and you'll be
able to find the books,
the articles,
the thinkers,
everything that we've mentioned in this conversation.
And until next time.
Of course.
Thank you for listening and along.
I hope to see you in person sometime soon and thanks again so much.
Bye Bye.
Okay guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short,
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one and if you
sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs or one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers from around the world and here's how it
works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward and many of you who are listening have already used it
and created some amazing things that I'll be sharing in the future,
but in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim that's 99 designs.com forward slash
hip
episode is brought to you by Vimeo pro,
which is the ideal video hosting platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a bunch
of my startups already use Vimeo pro including wealth front who uses it to
explain how wealth front works task grab.
It uses it to tell the company story and there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers,
airbnb,
Etsy,
et cetera.
Why do they use it?
Well,
dimio pro provides enterprise level video hosting for a fraction of the usual
cost.
Features include gorgeous high quality playback with no ads up to 20 gigabytes
of video storage every week.
Unlimited plays in views and they fully customizable video player,
which can include your logo,
custom outro,
et cetera.
You'll also get VIP support,
and you get all of this for just one 99 per year.
That's $17 a month with no complicated bandwidth calculations or hidden fees,
and you can try it risk free for 30 days.
So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business,
that's v I,
m e o.com forward slash business and use Promo Code Tim to get 25% off.
That's a special discount just for you guys.
So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business promo code.
Tim,
and until next time,
thank you for listening.